welcome back to new rockstars miss
marvel's bangles were stolen off of a
blue corpse could we be could we be
looking at our first hints at kamala's
cree heritage or should we send a
gargamel a congratulations card for a
job well done either way there probably
isn't going to be a third avatar movie
but this is rogue theory the show where
we pitch the wildest theories for the
nerdy titles that we love my name is mt
and going rogue with me today is the
future queen of the kree empire and most
likely to pull the fire alarm at your
wedding it's jessica clements what's
going on jess hi
hi
i'm just giving you a fire alarm
and once you know it the captain of the
clandestines it's my boy off-screen
producer
brandon leader of the clandestines did
you empty did you insinuate that the
blue body was an avatar you think it was
you think it was jake oh yeah i did
either avatar a smurf um some type of
other blue uh maybe uh one of the blue
men group men um i mean if disney if
disney brings avatar into the mcu i'll
be impressed synergy synergy
you have eight
multiverse synergy
um
pandora's box is just
the mcu in general um and the current
vice king of the inhuman empire it's tom
michelson what's going on yes um unlike
blackballed i can't talk but i'll just
talk very quietly yes i am the vice king
of the inhumans i just got to be very
quiet cause if i get loud then people's
ears hurt but it's not from a sonic
scream they just don't like my voice
[Laughter]
all right gang so knowing this new
format where i pitch a theory and you
guys tell me whether you're not you
think it's rogues or bogus or maybe you
just you know whether or not you're
approved or not i'm going to shoot you
guys with a weird theory about miss
marvel you guys ready for this oh yeah
do it let's hear it
okay yeah ready for this now guys i'm
not sure if you notice but that arm that
najma and aisha came across was bluer
than an eiffel 65 music video from the
year 1998. now isn't that suspicious
well i think that this could be proof
that the cree were involved with
humanity for hundreds of years prior to
aisha and najma finding the bengal
especially since we know that creed
blood doesn't have the right ingredients
for evolution like human does especially
in the comics and thus means that the
cree are incapable of becoming super
powered people like your monikas your
kamalas or your carols aka
mana kamala danvers uh that's my way
mana kamala
you're forcing people to spell it out
department
understandable makes complete sense now
it all checks out now mt loves md
monica mala danvers all right anyway so
what would be the cree's next best
solution oh i don't know how about an
interdimensional bangle that unlocks the
creep potential to be a super powered
being because we know from the end of
captain marvel that ronin the accuser
and the kree empire were very interested
in the human weapons of earth you know
you're like captain marvel with ronin
himself vowing to come back for the
weapon meaning carol danvers he was like
i'm gonna come back for you because man
you destroy all those ships really good
and i
i didn't want some of that for the glory
of the for the
supreme intelligence now so what if the
cree learned that these super old cosmic
bangles that came bundled with the 10
rings from the meteor that struck
wakanda
like millions like thousands of years
ago and wanted that bangle for
themselves so that they can learn how to
unlock their ability to do super powered
[ __ ]
what do you guys think
so you think the bangle and the ten
rings
were already made came in the same
meteor they were inside them someone put
them in the meteor so this was like a
loot drop yes in fortnite or something
right this is like
you said it completely right i don't
know what you said or something like
that seems like you really play these
games but i don't know
is that what the kids are doing is that
the minecraft is that minecraft is this
is this minecraft we're talking about
but like so do you think it was like a
celestial like put
some like super
uh some super op devices inside of a
meteor and just like chucked it into the
solar system and was like somebody come
find it i think that could very well be
the case or maybe even because someone
still has to make it right yeah or maybe
even um this is just a wild idea maybe
he who remains like tossed like a chunk
of vibranium of [ __ ] he's like all right
here's some [ __ ] that's
chaos
gonna
he went through he went through one
universe and he's like oh this next time
i'm going to put some extra
extra loot out there
for this actually [ __ ] in this one wait
so are you saying it's the same meteor
with the vibranium that came with
vibranium it came with bangles it came
with rings ah or is it a second one
you're saying it's the same one i think
that like there's one big event that
killed the dinosaurs maybe we know from
black panther that um
killmonger said that wakanda was like in
africa in general was the center place
of civilization that's where everything
popped off so like i think that
before like pangaea split apart maybe
this meteor caused pangaea to split
apart and like spread off different um
artifacts to different parts of the
world um and so we get the vibranium and
wakanda and then the ten rings gets
picked up by wenwu and um you know and
then this uh bengal gets lost in was it
pakistan yeah i mean
um
what
they were looking for the other one in
the first one too
uh and when i say the first one i met
like with the
grandmamas the grandma moms were like we
don't know where the first one is i
don't want to put a hat on a hat uh
especially on your theory mt but like
you made me think like the other time
something struck the earth was when the
celestial tiana was planted do you think
maybe he left behind you know what i
mean like that that like magical stuff
came with him and he just was planted in
the center of the earth but like this
other mystical energies or powers were
left behind in these artifacts i don't
know i never thought of that until you
mention that but i was like damn that
you know that that's a really good idea
because you know they're trying to tie
all this [ __ ] together like from
chungchi to this you know like and i'm
sure eternals phase all this space for
stuff they're really trying to tie it
all in so i thought of that
i would love if like this was just part
of like celestial technology that was
left behind from there um when they were
just here and it's like just doing weird
[ __ ] like i feel like that makes a lot
of sense considering that you know in
this new phase we got eternals and we
got um you know just
like they're they're sort of just like
introducing the celestials like hey we
are the players like we are going to
[ __ ] [ __ ] up very soon and like we we
have been involved in earth's um
evolution so like this could very well
be um celestial gear left behind from
when they dropped that celestial seed
into the middle of the planet um so yeah
this that makes a lot of sense i like
that
i'll tell you what i
don't like about your theory first
yes go for it
this is what i don't
that
there is a meteor floating through space
with just the
the right
pieces of equipment
that is needed for the humans on earth
616.
that is what i don't like i don't like
that it's like out of
when you assume there'd be more meteors
when you assume there'd be much more
technology not just like the bengals and
the 10 rings which i'm also already
irritated about being like okay so we're
saying the bengals and the ten rings
made by the same people on the same
meteor but i'm gonna tell you what i
like about your theory i'm gonna tell
you i'm gonna tell you what i like about
it this is like a chef cooking show this
is other [ __ ]
but
[Laughter]
this is the worst thing i've ever had in
my life yeah yeah
but not just
that's what i'm doing
so
though
i hate it let me tell you what i like
i also hate
um that there is that i do like though
that it it's basically um what are they
called um
when we find um not artifacts but when
we find it in the rocks like pieces like
old bones and stuff and then we are well
that's the job what's the actual thing
fossil a fossil thank you
god that's the job
archaeologists
you know what i mean
so i like the idea of the equipment
being fossilized on something and it is
just floating through space because that
is what it would be because they're on a
different planet so i do i'm like i'm
like oh it makes me mad that all these
pieces of equipment would be on one
meteor but then i'm also like
but it could
but it could and
damn well could after
everything has been happening if just
some pieces got left behind on something
even if it was a fossil that fossil
being the rock floating through space
and finds itself on a random planet
because then it's not just earth six one
six it could be well it would be six one
six if it would just be earth it'd be
other planets that also got that piece
of equipment we just haven't visited
those planets yet we're just looking at
this one right here so ultimately
would i make a deal with you
i would
but
it goes against it goes against my
future
so
i feel like i'm upset
do i get my funding here's what i'm
confused about mt with this whole like
creed thing because i do think that
career involved somehow
and especially with like the blue skin
which how long was that dead body there
for why was do i do creed decompose like
that's the other thing that's something
you think about but also
yeah
so
are we just like ignoring that they
called themselves the gyms that's my
next part right is that like well they
were saying like this is what people
have called us they've called us
jin they've called us you know whatever
whatever
different names they're not and they're
just taking that name for sake of the
story i think because i think they're
hiding who they really are because the
whole dimension thing is what's throwing
me off like why are these cree from like
another dimension and not just like from
outer space are these cree that were
like kicked out of the cree world
for their beliefs their weird religious
beliefs i also think you know
because i think the way they're going to
bring mutants into the mcu is like have
them coming from another dimension or
another universe and like they're
refugees in a way i'm wondering if
they're if kamala is like a mutant and
like they're gonna make the x gene
they're gonna mix like in humans and
mutants in a weird way where it's like
the x gene can get activated inside of
people kind of like instead of doing
like pterogenesis and all that stuff
that's what bruno said he was coming in
from inside of her yeah
yeah yeah like you have this everyone
like maybe every human has like a next
gene or maybe just like descendants of
mutants have this x gene uh
and it can be like activated and like
they're not really gin or they're not
uh
uh
um clandestines or whatever words that
she was saying she was just saying that
to kamala like i don't i don't trust
anything this lady has to say uh but
maybe they're like mutant refugees or
something and they're trying to find
like a new home world but they want to
go back i don't know i'm really confused
how long has this creed body been
waiting
no when you brought that up like this
made me think about like the possibility
of like what if the dimension that like
najma and all of them came from was an
alternate universe where the humans are
already established the agents of shield
universe where we know that the cree are
have already popped should like pop [ __ ]
off so like what if they're just a group
of inhumans that call themselves the
clandestines because like they're in a
different region of the world so like
not everyone's gonna call themselves the
same things in different regions of the
world so it's like all right we're from
this from this agency universe
multiverse is broken because of he who
remains and like like wormholes are
opening up and [ __ ] what if like you
know they got tossed in one of those
wormholes as to be exiled and like
they're like all right we gotta get home
or else we're gonna cause a freaking
incursion um and that'd be really fun
and like the cree are also from that
other universe and so they're like all
right
um we have this bengal and we should
probably i don't know i'm just throwing
it over
what you're saying actually is kind of
come i actually i'm kind of combining
with a little bit of what i was thinking
last night when i was hearing them talk
about yeah they're the clandestine and
you they're really you know you know
they're kind of evil and stuff but
you know and then so getting it back to
your original theory about it being
decree yeah i think it has i think the
cree
um trying to find or create weapons uh
you know uh we're using the using the
special jewelry is
spot-on makes sense but for a second
last night when i was watching and they
were talking about how come they don't
age and how often they've been around i
was like are these
evil skrulls maybe
like because we know we're setting up
for secret invasion and stuff that's
coming out these girls are gonna have to
be evil at some point for that to happen
i would imagine we need some evils
we need evil sprawls right so so maybe
this was maybe the crashing was like
um
like i don't know if you guys watched
beast wars i totally did but like you
know that there were there's a war of
the cree and the skrulls kind of like
the maxis protocons and then they
they're fighting and they crash on earth
um and that's where these artifacts are
found but so maybe these were so maybe
this they're squirrels that killed
the creed are trying to get their
weapons and they can't use them and now
they're kind of stuck on earth from this
dimensions and stuff so i was just
trying to think because now that we've
firmly attached this to shang qi and now
that of course captain marvel we're
connected to the cream like they're
still planting seeds for what's coming
down the the pike and i was thinking
well with secret invasion coming soon
and with these guys being you know uh
shifty characters i was like maybe
maybe the squirrels had something to do
with it so i was just trying to tie what
i was thinking with what you said is
essentially what's happening but
yeah i was like i never thought of that
i really like that they could be like
super skulls right like they have
abilities they're stronger than regular
scrolls yeah dude i cannot wait to see
people
i cannot wait this could be the turning
point where we're all like oh there's
scrolls
my cat just attacked the [ __ ] out of my
hand
oh my god i hate her oh no
i'll just say you played it off very
well
uh
i think it can go two ways and i would
be obviously clearly
you don't want to be in my hands stop um
i think
it could be that watch them us be like
their scrolls their scrolls or whatever
around the scrolls but then they're
actually going down the right of
eternals and being like cosmic d like
gods
because i'm like a piece of me is like
when i when they were first like the gin
i was like oh the demon ghost if you
play a lot of uh spooky uh video games
you know what a gin is so i was like oh
it's a spooky ghost it's a demon and
then when we i was like or maybe their
version of this demon is just a
scroll but then i was like or watch them
just be going the route of eternals and
celestials and we're just we think that
they're gonna go the cree route but
watch them be like
godly beings
godly demons god demons
that's a bummer view that's my bummer
account i'm gonna pick up my cat
[Laughter]
if they if they are though if they were
cree
and they're or they're park cree and
they're like in humans for lack of a a
better term you know the creed don't
like the inhumans right because they're
because the supreme intelligence was
like the humans are going to destroy the
creed that you got to stop the
experiments so it would make sense that
the cree would like banish them to like
another dimension and be like you guys
got to go here like a phantom zone maybe
yeah that's like their own version the
mcu phantom zone but it is strange that
like they wanna like najma wants to get
back to this other zone but like why do
you wanna leave this realm so badly
she's like we gotta get back with our
people but
it didn't look chill when when when
kamala kind of
dripped into it it didn't look very
chill everyone looked kind of intense
and angry and
glowing eyes i was like i don't know i
want to live there and something
something's got to blow up for them to
go back too yeah so i mean who knows man
that's it
it seems pretty popping like if to have
glowing eyes it's it's pretty nice
i don't even have like my eyes are just
like straight up black
but also yeah light eyes sounds very
stupid i don't want it i like to be
while i'm in the dark i like to not be
hidden or i like to be hidden i like to
be
in the shadows not caught i mean
especially since me and you fight crime
every night
together obviously i just like to hide
and then jump out and scare people oh
yes
no no that's that's just that's your
role because like i you're the
distraction i have you be the
distraction that you hide and they come
back don't forget your
[Laughter]
celebrations
but no okay so
let's say this is time for judgments now
because i have now delivered my theory
now what do you guys think overall do
you think that this theory of the cree
wanting to use these these bangles for
the to unlock their evolutionary biology
before it gets stolen by aisha and the
gang do you think that's too rogue
i'm starting off with brandon rogue or
rogueis or bogus brandon no i i like
this i like this theory i'll call it
rogus because
yeah i think the cree they do
they're scared of these bangles because
of what it unlocks i think it's tracking
with that inhuman kind of storyline like
they
they want this evolutionary power back
uh
but the the overall crew are scared of
it and they want to destroy it
full stop
yeah
all right one vote for the theory what
you think tom
i think i'm gonna
give it two rogue thumbs up also i i
like i i should have i should have like
obviously they're planning captain
marvel 2 and stuff so the cree are going
to be a big part of this we're going
into space as opposed to being more like
shanxi maybe you know talo related
and uh so i really like that i and and
thought about how
how uh the cree would want to use this
new weapons technology but then like
evolving and becoming more powerful and
yeah it makes sense and it tracks for
what we'll probably be setting up for
captain marvel 2 and it tracks for what
the world of the show is building so
two rogue thumbs up oh all right thanks
tom now jeff saving the best for last of
course jessica clemens
do i
what is the final shark member think
[Music]
i bet you're watching
i bet you're waiting to see where it
goes it's staying right there oh
we did our first
little thumb i'll do slightly i'm
leaning more
bogus oh wait rogues
i think just a little bit of spice just
a little bit of spice and i'd be
completely rogues don't think it's bogus
i think it's far from bogus but i'm just
not going to give it the full it's like
getting a b minus it's like giving a b
it's just
yeah it's just
i'm also allowed to be really stingy
about my votes because i win rogue
theory i used to win rogue theory all
the time so i'm allowed to be stingy i'm
like the queen of this [ __ ]
[Music]
i think i'm gonna actually just
implement that oh that's kind of funny
all right i'll take it two and a half
thumbs up thanks guys
um well um but up next we are going to
talk about who is really leading the
department of damage control but first
some capitalism head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to grab our miss
marvel themed latest obsession shirt
cosmic daydream this limited edition
shirt will not be available for long and
when you purchase this shirt you unlock
the ability to get a custom shout out on
inside marvel or miss marvel after show
it's also your last chance to get our
obi-wan kenobi theme delay this
obsession shirt as well so check out all
of our awesome merch options over at new
rockstars merch.com and we want to thank
bluetooth for sponsoring this video guys
it's time to bring that summer heat into
the bedroom for once in your gosh dang
life confidence can take you far in life
it can also help in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate if you know what i mean
that's where blue chew comes in before
you do
sorry
fat empty bad empty
that gets too close for me
[Laughter]
that's where bluetooth comes in buchu is
a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable tablets and
at a fraction of the cost you can take
them any time day or night so you can
plan ahead or just be ready whenever the
opportunity arises process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days and the
best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy because that's the worst
blue chews tablets are made in the usa
paired and shipped direct to your door
in a discrete package it's time to get
off the couch and back to work if your
tool needs an upgrade head to
bluetooth.com so if you can benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform loot you can help and we've got
a special deal for our listeners try
blue chew free when you use our promo
code rogue at checkout just pay five
dollars of shipping that's bluechew.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we thank blue shoe for sponsoring this
podcast and also we want to thank stance
because since i got my stand socks i've
made a solemn vow that they're the only
socks that you will wear ever again so
you can imagine how excited that i am to
hear that stance is now expanding their
scope to a full active apparel line my
emotions cannot handle this news i'm so
excited because they've got everything
from shorts and sweats to hoodies and
hats and it's all so soft and colorful
people and if you enjoy the comfort and
creativity of stance in the past you're
not going to believe what all stance has
in store from now tommy recently gifted
me stance apparel and i can't believe
how incredibly soft it is i thought
stance only made socks but now they're
making everything from joggers and
sweats to huggies and hats and it's all
really comfortable and super colorful
with versatile style that you can wear
almost anywhere it's not just socks
anymore stan is bringing color comfort
and creativity from toe to head for the
launch of our all-new active apparel
line that's right what started off as a
radical reinvention of your sock drawer
is now expanding to your entire wardrobe
check out stan's super soft line of
sweatpants and joggers shirts hoodies
hats and more now available in a full
range of fits prints fabrics and fun
embrace the life of superior comfort and
creative expression with everyday active
apparel that truly is stitch different
santa's philosophy is that you should
never have to sacrifice your individual
style for the sake of comfort and now
you don't have to so whether you're
relaxing around the house working out at
the gym or running all over the town
stance now delivers its signature
softness and creativity in a full line
of acts of apparel styles from toe to
head stance has got you covered head on
over to stance.com and get 15 off your
first purchase use promo code rogue at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary but
stands stitched different from cringing
at the pump to getting an eye-popping
check at your favorite restaurant
inflation is hitting us all where it
hurts and boy does it really hurt that's
why i started using upside upside is an
incredible app for anyone who buys gas
groceries or dines out with every
purchase i'm earning cashback thanks to
upside to get started download the free
upside app in the app store or google
play use our promo code rogue theory
that's all one word rogue theory and get
five dollars or more cash back on your
first purchase of ten dollars or more to
use the app all you gotta do is claim an
offer for whatever you're buying on
upside you then check in at the business
when you're there pay as usual with a
credit or debit card and then you get
paid from upside i've downloaded this
app i've used it at a couple different
gas stations it works great super easy
it's a great little rewards program
that's better than most things that
stores offer on their own in comparison
to credit card or rewards loyalty
programs you can earn up to three times
more cash back with upside you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
or an e-gift card for amazon and other
brands upside users are earning more
than a million dollars every week a
million dollars that's probably why they
have a 4.8 star rating in the app store
all you gotta do is download the free
upside app and use promo code rogue
theory that's one word rogue theory to
get five dollars or more cash back on
your first purchase of ten dollars or
more that's five dollars or more cash
back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more using promo code all one
word rogue theory when you download the
free upside app do it today it's a great
app it's super easy check it out thanks
outside
now that brandon has done this amazing
ad i want to let brandon do our second
topic for the day yes brandon take it
away okay i've got a very rogue theory
for you guys okay we've all seen how the
dodc is really getting powered up they
got weapons they got power to like
bust into wherever they want they're
taking kids off the street taking them
to their little holding cells right
the main guy we've met is agent p cleary
we don't know his first name all we know
is he's agent p cleary he's been running
the show ever since and he's spiderman
no way home well that's this is what i'm
getting at empty he has a little do
sheet right it seems like his partner
though she's a little more aggro he's
trying to tamper her down a little bit
but who is this agent p cleary where did
he come from here's my rogue theory okay
agent p cleary is nick fury in disguise
okay he's wearing one of those uh he's
wearing one of those black widow face
mesh things
i think
i think that after we saw nick fury last
and far from home when he was up on the
space station he's like where are my
shoes who stole my shoes okay
uh where's my mess he gets his shoes
back and he's like i gotta go down to
earth i gotta clean all this stuff up
right he becomes agent p clear and no
one knows that it's it's nick fury which
he loves to do he loves to sneak into
places shield is gone right this is the
new shield dodc is the new shield he's
taking it over and he we know how much
he love we know how much nick fury loves
interrogating teenagers he loves doing
it i think he saw it he saw what it's
his favorite thing to do he saw what
little peter porker got up to and far
from home he's like that's i gotta go
talk to this kid for real this time
but not as nick fury i'm gonna show
basic agent p killer cleary that's how
he has all that information on
spider-man that's always like personal
info right and now he's very interested
in what's going on you know with the
between the ten rings and now this like
bengals thing he's into what's going on
because like mtv's talking about you
know these are possibly cree that are
coming in people coming in from other
dimensions
we know that's like swords territory
right this like kind of like
otherworldly stuff so i think he's snuck
in he's taken over the dodc a government
organization so that he can be in charge
without the government knowing that it's
nick fury he's pretending to be p cleary
that's my theory that's my theory
brandon
brandon you know one thing that's yeah
do you smell that
it's certified fresh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a steal
that's my theory is that p theory is
really nick fury the thing about that
theory
um from board member number one is that
that is
rogue as hell right yeah check the box
for being rogue as hell
pretty plausible with the timeline
and also very plausible with how nick
fury acts except for right the one thing
i hate but still plausible you didn't
stop that racist woman
at the dodc when she was like same race
things
next big question um how much does nick
fury care about race because
i'm also like it is a nick fury thing to
be like well i see aliens every day i
see all these things and it's like yeah
but at the end of the day you're still a
black man in america my dude get with it
um but seriously i like him i like it i
like it i like it what could he be a
scroll instead of nick fury well i mean
that's that's a big theory right that p
clear is a scroll
but i i think that's a a fake out and i
think there is some changing going on
but it's nick fury it's not a scroll i i
can see this happening because we know
that secret invasion is coming up and
that seems to be a very spy type of show
between nick fury and the scroll race
and so like i can see nick fury
wanting to take over the dodc in secret
because like maybe the dotc has been
taken over by the squirrels and he's
like you know what i'm infiltrating the
infiltration and no one needs to like
i'm deep undercover because this is what
i do
it's a secret invasion sandwich
people are secretly invading all over
the place
it's completely for secret invasion and
also nick fury just learning just being
undercover at the doc but specifically
more in cover undercover and cover to
figure out who miss marvel is because
they're like this woman kind of has
similar tropes to captain marvel and so
it could be like there's a girl running
around town dressed as you but with
actual superpowers and they'll she'd be
like what what are you talking about
it'd be like there's another you around
here so i think it'd be very important
going into the marvels and secret
invasion for him to be undercover
learning so much about the new
superheroes that are coming also the
avengers have fallen apart so they don't
have a new team right now so it's like i
need another i need to know well it
makes sense why they're looking for like
enhanced
uh people right especially like young
kids that way he's like i'm tired of
dealing with like adults that i gotta
like manage their all their issues i'm
just gonna get a group of kids together
you can pay kids less money not only
because they're children but because
they're so happy to be working with
their heroes and it's like
free life
but i i especially like this theory
because like in the comics and i believe
in the agents of shield universe if i'm
not um mistaken there's this thing
called uh the life model decoys um
they're they're basically like human
looking robots that like were just like
they they very much look like humans and
like you can mistaken them for humans
and they can trick people out and i
think that maybe agent cleary could be a
nick fury like model decoy that like
talks like cleary but like aidan i mean
uh nick fury's just talking through oh
like he's continuing
like men in black he's like he's like a
little alien inside he's like
it's like it's auto ryan's belt yeah
yeah
um i um this reminds me hold on let me
let me check my notes real quick yeah
that's rogue as hell brandon that's
really rogue uh yeah
i can feel it
out of a justice playbook no i i of
course yeah i never thought of that but
that's really a fun theory because um
you know like you said the the
department of damage control is kind of
like a mini shield like they already
look we already have the start drones
now and then shield reappropriates start
tech real quick like in winter soldier
the helicarriers now had repulsors and
uh and and every time you know there's
some new kind of tech they can take and
use for themselves they do and so so
yeah some of these weapons some of the
things they do is very shield-like and
so yeah
going back on what mt was saying is that
i was thinking well if there was a way
instead of yeah instead of nick fury
maybe using the black widow mask which
could still work yeah because he's maybe
he's still in space and he's controlling
a life model decoy of this guy so he can
have it you know he can um he can do
both things at the same time i i never
thought of that but yeah that's a really
fun theory
the stark drones is a good point because
i think that's also why nick fury came
down to take over because he saw that
like what happens in far from home he's
like oh [ __ ] the government's going to
take everything
that star goes i need to find out what
happened with edith and i need to figure
all this out you know talos wasn't
getting the job done and he's like and
talos is not doing a good job as me so i
need it yeah yeah i need to get out
there and get some [ __ ] done so yeah i
like that and that's also why he told he
told peter parker like oh nick fury's
been in space for a year just because he
wanted to see the look on peter's face
and he knew immediately you're right he
knew it right off the top of his head
like very few people no nick fury's
movement and why would you damage
control guys i know that yeah that's so
random
exactly like that is very sketchy so
like i definitely feel like there is
some type of nick fury knowledge just
like or some coordination to some degree
because yeah i was thinking he might
have been a squirrel too because the
scrolls would then know and tell each
other like hey p cleary squirrel like
you know nick fury's up here so that's
why he'd know but yeah he's cool don't
worry about it's cool but um but yeah uh
yeah some kind of like life model d
chord bringing back that black widow
mass is good every time so yeah
yes oh man i need more of that
technology in the mcu just randomly
right like uh
and then sometimes you can change your
height and like
yeah exactly
frogman is nick fury there we tied it
all together
but no i like what you brought up tom
about um how
damage control is sort of the new shield
because like it very much is it's
basically it feels like shield with a
different name now if they're slowly
just
and like i feel like nick fury because
of everything that happened in uh winter
soldier he's probably like you know what
this new organization that's not shield
but basically is shield is really just
gathering a lot of power and resources
and like let's i gotta see what's going
on here so let me infiltrate as agent
cleary to see uh what's what the whole
what the true um purpose of the dodc is
because like i think that hydra because
like i'd be super sketched out with
hydra or like hydrogen's rise after
having the organization that i spent my
entire life working in
being like all right that was a lie so
like i have to go check these guys out
so i could i can see that uh agent
cleary for sure i'm working with nick
fury or being nick fury um but yes but
let's do
our final judgement on brandon yeah
judge this story i dare you fellow
sharks
starting with jess
what is your vote for brandon's theory
shark jest
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
beautiful okay
like that vote because i myself
will give you a thumbs up as well
it's very rogue i like it
and tom what do you think buddy
i wish i had more hands so i can give
this theory
[Applause]
it was so rogue and so fun and it made
me think about things i never thought of
especially like the shield connection
but
nick fury and a mascot
i think
but who knows who knows they could do
anything but i was like that was just
one if you said life model decoy i would
have been like okay i can maybe buy that
but i don't i think nick here's his face
you know like eating and drinking his
pizza and enjoying things so
hands full thumbs down
but i still like you brandon
yes
well that's i still i really like the
theory but it's basically i didn't
really like my pleasure and it had a lot
of good points for sure yeah but now uh
back by popular demand it is time
for our rogue
questions questions
a recent trailer for thor love and
thunder showed what appeared to be
celestials looking in on a gathering of
gods with zeus what is your wrongest
reason why some celestials would be at
the council of godheads busting the
party
i think they're not busting the party i
think these are two celestials that zeus
like
won over or like
took control of or took as his own baby
boys because we know how he likes to go
around the universe uh uh banging women
and taking their kids uh i think i think
these two celestials they're under
zeus's control and they're like the
valets because they were like outside i
think they're like the valets and when
all these gods show up in different cars
or whatever vehicles they use to get
there they they chuck the key to a
celestial and like the celestials to go
park it that's what i think they are
they're the valets
i like that i don't know if uh if you
guys watch adventure time but like it
kind of reminds me of the gumball
guardians of the uh the candy kingdom or
like
it's like they're just big gumball like
like they're sort of like celestials and
anyway
but you as well just
you're too young for me
sorry me too be time with you brandon
i'm with you all night
i just think celestial's deep down like
the party
also i think
so not only do they like to party i
think it's like
you know like
they kind of have to you know and i feel
like the celestials are like if one of
us has to go like one of us has to go to
this party and it's like i don't want to
go it's like well one of us has to go so
we're gonna have to draw straws and see
which one of us is gonna show up i think
it's one of those party ways like
because they're so big that's like we
still are like a community we have to go
join them for their stuff but it's like
i don't want to go so only two of them
went because they're like we don't all
want to go
i was like the opposite of you jess
because i was i was like oh crap the
slushies are coming did you i thought we
weren't fighting i thought we weren't
either and now they show up
[Music]
thanks for coming guys
i gotta entertain them all kind of a
mess here
we ate all of your chips
we need more chips thank you for the
guac yeah take the whole bowl of snacks
let's see that's why we don't invite the
celestials god these guys are right i
think i might have broken your toilet
sorry
i planted a new celestial in your toilet
and it's like what
i'm saying you're gonna stay here for 80
000 years exactly it'll grow and when it
finally grows it will blow up this
mountain
yeah yeah then it's like and you're
piping he's like that planet has my baby
that planet has my baby that one too has
my baby oh my god i want to invite them
because i'd be like you they're like
dogs you see them dating in the backyard
get out of here
exactly so i would imagine that they're
like oh god we got advice
yeah the unwanted guests they're the
unwanted guests like the neighbors and
the guy you know their godly
neighborhood they're like the neighbors
be like well we can't not invite him
it's gonna be too obvious so all right
just yeah they'll see it they'll see
everyone's here they're gonna know
something's going on it's like we
brought you other planets
like i don't want to eat these planets
just put them on the table
no i like i love these rogue answers but
like i think the uninvited neighbors is
my favorite scenario there because like
my god it's just like oh man here they
are it's like hey you you guys were
meeting with us
we made you it's like
it's like ah yeah you made everybody all
right i could see taika with tt doing a
really comedic take on the uh these
celestials like i would love to see
two just funny celestials like yeah
we're just hanging out i guess and like
we don't really we have no animosity
we're just doing our jobs you know um so
yeah i'm going to give you
the report i don't think really do wrong
points anymore but i will give you the
credits i will vote
my uh
my host powers for you and your answer
yeah
um so there you go the winner of the
wrong question
but that is it for this episode of rogue
theory i want to thank our amazing
amazing guests jessica clemens tom
michelson and off-screen producer
brandon for being on here today i love
you guys so much you're so smart and um
yeah you guys i love spending time with
you guys um and you guys are watching
can support our channel by checking out
all of our awesome merch options over at
new rockstarsmerch.com and if you've got
your own world theories you can share
them on our discord um if you're over 18
just search for the new rockstar discord
server on discord and join the
conversation you can follow me
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] you can
follow the new rockstars on all our
social platforms and be sure to hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a
video and subscribe to our youtube
channel here on youtube in general we'll
see you guys next time we love you and
have a great day bye bye
[Music]
you